at noon more progress on the fountain
blue today the unfinished North strip
property and the resort gave a bit of a
clear idea of when it'll finally open it
says the company says it's set to open
its doors to the public now in December
that's about 15 years after it was
supposed to open but as you know never
did but this is some new drone video
from today you can see the resort the
pool area that's some of the work
they've been doing you maybe haven't
seen from the street today's
announcement marks the beginning of
hiring efforts at the fountain blue it's
expected to create thousands of jobs the
online job listing portal is now open
you can find a link posted at
8newsnow.com